wirtschaftsminister hubert aiwanger und
gesundheitsministerin melanie huml der
ministerpräsidenten vielen dank auch von
meiner seite ein herzliches grüß gott
köhler hält uns weiter in atem die
bevölkerung die wirtschaft die
gesellschaft aber eben auch das
bayerische kabinett wir haben uns heute
wieder intensiv beschäftigt wie der
weitere weg aus dieser schwierigen zeit
in dieser schwierigen zeit ist
eines kann man festhalten auch wenn die
zahlen in deutschland halbwegs stabil
sind bis auf einige regionale ausbrüche
abgesehen ist es so dass eine wachsende
unsicherheit bei der bevölkerung viele
menschen sind besorgt weil sie leicht
sind verspüren und auch merken dass da
ein anderer die zurückgegebenen
verantwortung
doch etwas leichtfertiger annimmt und
damit möglicherweise einen rückfall
riskieren kann
für uns ist eines ganz klar wir wollen
diesen leichtsinn nicht unterstützen im
gegenteil wir wollen weiter vorsicht und
umsicht an erster stelle setzen denn die
situation ist nach wie vor sehr
zerbrechlich was ist jederzeit in
flammen war
die ereignisse der letzten tage und
wochen zeigen dass innerhalb kürzester
zeit durch eine infektion viel entstehen
können und wenn wir nicht rasch und
konsequent handelt bis hin zu klaren
quarantänemaßnahmen dann kann es
passieren dass es sehr schnell gehen
kann und wir aber erneut einen ausbruch
der infektionen in vielen ländern der
welt ist die zweite welle bereits da und
die länder überlegen wie sie darauf
reagieren die einigen kündigen neue
lockdown sun in andere länder
beispielsweise in usa einzelner governor
bedauern ausdrücklich beispielsweise in
texas wie ich gelesen habe dass man zu
früh geleistet und gelockert hat und
sind wir ganz ehrlich auch bei uns gibt
es so einen schleichenden prozess
ob es eine zweite welle wird eine
dauerwelle ist egal
die herausforderung bleibt jedenfalls
konstant da und nach dem urlaub wird
sich ab zu warten nach dem sommer wird
abzuwarten sein ob wir eine stärkere
entwicklung haben dass die uv-strahlung
dazu führt dass infektionen sinken kann
jedenfalls im internationalen vergleich
so wenn man die ausbruch situation in
israel in den südlichen staaten den usa
sieht oder bei uns nicht automatisch
banken also
wir bleiben vorsichtig wir bleiben
vorsichtig und wir bleiben auch in
bayern bei der strategien wir haben uns
da wieder intensiv beraten
langsamer ist als andere zu machen
deswegen haben wir heute keine weiteren
grundlegenden öffnungen beschlossen
sondern wir warten die öffnung und jetzt
getätigt worden abschauen wie das
infektionsgeschehen darauf reagiert und
überlegen dann erst die nächsten schritt
dass wir bleiben bei dem kurs doch
vorsicht des zeitlichen abwartens und
gehen nicht den weg alles sehr schnell
zu machen und dann auch sehr schnell
wieder zurückrudern zu müssen
das einzige was man heute gemacht haben
war eine anpassung dass wir wir bleiben
natürlich bei allen regeln von abstand
halten hygiene mund nasenschutz werden
eine ausnahme ist zugelassen wir stellen
den kulturbereich gleich zum zu der
bereich der kirche an den gottesdiensten
dort haben wir entschieden dass
drumherum eine masken pflicht ist aber
dann wenn man auf seinem platz ist und
der entsprechen mehr abstand gewahrt ist
das dann eine maske nicht notwendig ist
dieses modell übertragen wir jetzt das
ist die einzige änderung die wir gemacht
haben
daneben haben wir beschlossen unsere
präventionsmaßnahmen deutlich
auszuweiten
testen ist prävention testen ist die de
facto einzige möglichkeit des staates zu
reagieren
denn wenn man genau hinschaut bedeutet
es ja dass die überwiegenden maßnahmen
die bürger selber zu treffen haben
der staat gibt der gesellschaft und den
bürgern auflagen abstand halten distanz
hygienemaßnahmen und eben auch die
entsprechenden mund nasenschutz die
einzige möglichkeit des staates schutz
zurückzugeben selbst ist zu testen
deswegen ist ganz klar und völlig
unbestritten ebenfalls überwiegend das
testen testen testen einzige chance ist
um infektionskette zu unterbrechen damit
infektionen einzudämmen und eine
reaktion zu finden auf krone nun wir
haben uns jetzt diese aufgabe noch
einmal besonders gestellt bayern war
beim thema testen bislang eigentlich
schon ganz gut unterwegs
wir haben auf 1000 einwohner umgerechnet
im internationalen vergleich eine höhere
quote als österreich italien schweden
südkorea und auch besser als der
bundesdurchschnitt ist zu ergeben
recherchen
wir haben bislang über eine million
tests bereits durchgeführt über eine
million tests
wichtig ist dabei dass wir ja nicht etwa
zufällig agieren sondern systematisch
vorgehen wenn wir uns jetzt aber noch
mal entschieden diese strategie zu
verfeinern zu effektiveren und
auszuhalten
ich bin der festen überzeugung wer
dauerhaft mehr lockert muss umgekehrt
auch mehr testen
man kann nicht nur immer erleichtern man
muss einen gegenzug ein angebot machen
dass das testen
übrigens ist testen ein frühwarnsystem
testen ist auch vorbeugung nicht erst
wenn sozusagen alles brennt oder wenn
die infektionszahlen ansteigen zu testen
vorher es zu machen um möglicherweise
auch entsprechende ergebnisse zu ziehen
wir haben einzelne fälle wo es uns zu
ausbrüchen gramm und ist auch vorsorge
zum teil getestet wurden von ärzten zum
beispiel der spargelhof im schwäbischen
und schon wurde es erkannt und eine
größere ausbreitung konnte damit
lokalisiert und dann auch verhindert
werden
und wir dürfen am ende nicht sparen auf
kosten der sicherheit
es wird dieser tage sehr viel geld mobil
gemacht in deutschland für alles
mögliche für diesen bereich brauchen wir
dringend weitere möglichkeiten
daher gilt es das test konzept
auszuweiten und so zu formulieren unser
test konzept lautet schneller kostenlos
und für jedermann schneller kostenlos
und für jedermann
die ausgangslage war ja so dass damals
am höhepunkt der pandemie sehr große
unsicherheit herrscht
viele leute die symptome hatten selbst
symptome hatten und einen arzt gefragt
des gesundheitsamt wurden auf tage
vertröstet ging mit kapazitäten zusammen
aber viele menschen die unsicher waren
ob sie vielleicht wird jemand kontakt
haben wurden auf lange wochen oder auf
symptome stärkere symptome vertröstet
wir wollen hier an der stelle die
wartezeiten reduzieren sicherheit geben
und damit insgesamt für unser land eine
bessere struktur finden bei uns geht es
jetzt nicht nur davon einfach irgendwie
für alle sondern wir haben einen klaren
weg definiert
die argumente die gegen ein
ausgeweitetes test konzept sprechen
überzeugen uns nicht das argument es
genannt wird
das ist ja nur für den moment geht für
jeden test würde man das argument als
einziges gelten lassen würde es bedeuten
man braucht gar nicht testen oder wartet
bis zum ende jeder test und vor allem
viele tests helfen
testen ist also keine einmalaktion 2
das argument es sei jetzt sehr teuer
kann kein argument sein denn wir dürfen
an dieser stelle nicht auf sicherheit
der bürger sparen sondern im gegenteil
wir müssen da eine ergebnis bringen und
das dritte argument es da kommen würde
das sei nicht gezielt können wir in
bayern bewusst widerlegen herum
wir haben ein klares system wie geht es
erstens natürlich ist verdacht das
symptom der erste und wichtigste fall
das testen ganz klar jeder der symptome
hat bekommt eine 24 stunden garantie in
24 stunden ein test und in 24 stunden
dann ergebnis heißt der versuch der
maximalen sicherheit
hinzu kommt es bei allen anderen
verdachtsfällen gerade dort wo die
herausforderung da ist wo es schon
entsprechende symptome gibt also nicht
nur der dass symptome hat sondern der
als kontaktperson in der nähe ist oder
der auch mit entsprechenden
verdachtsfällen in berührung kommen
könnte also die erste priorität ganz
klar bei verdacht zweitens wir bieten
umfassende reihenuntersuchungen an
reihenuntersuchung heißt öfters und
freiwillig öfters und freiwillig zum
beispiel für das gesamte medizinische
personal sowie regelmäßige tests wollen
also nicht nur einmal regelmäßig
bedeutet den krankenhäusern im
medizinischen bereich alten und
pflegeheimen behinderteneinrichtungen
alles was dazugehört freiwillig dann
insbesondere für den bereich der
lehrerinnen lehrer der erzieherin
erzieher wir hören da aus den
berufsgruppen große sympathie dafür das
angebot anzunehmen
es gilt zum einen name war jetzt hier
der regelbetrieb bei der kita wieder
anfängt zum ersten juli und auf der
anderen seite weil wir die situation
dass wir nach dem urlaub sowieso in
einer
hoffentlich situationen sind dass wir
keine großen sorgen haben wir für den
fall der fälle ist dadurch sicherheit
für die pädagogen für die eltern aber
auch für die schüler wichtig und
gleiches gilt übrigens auch für polizei
justiz oder wunsch und bedarf relativ
großes also erste stufe bei verdacht
zwei freiwillige reichen
reihenuntersuchungen bei besonders
betroffenen berufsgruppen und drittens
dann eben ohne symptome sind wird in
kürzester zeit die garantie gegeben dass
eine möglichkeit besteht einen test zu
machen und den dann auch zeitnah zu
erhalten
dieses zitat einzig dass wir das machen
in deutschland es ist übrigens meiner
mal nach nach dem urlaub ein sehr gutes
angebot für die sicherheit viele
menschen jetzt gerade in urlaub fahren
haben dann eine erhöhte sicherheit wenn
sie zurückkommen und ist damit auch ein
angebot für die sicherheit in der breite
der bevölkerung
wir werden das konzept stückweise
hochfahren jetzt ab ersten juli beginnt
das gesundheitsministerium hat es
erarbeitet
in ganz hervorragende arbeit vielen dank
auch melanie für die für die arbeit der
letzten tage derzeit nur normal dass man
die einschätzung hat das haben wir
10.000 tests ungefähr am tag wir haben
aber die kapazität von 20.000 wir
erhöhen die kapazität auf 30.000 pro tag
so dass wir all die ganzen bereich
abdecken
wir gehen nicht davon aus dass jeder
muss und will
aber wer möchte der hat die chance
keiner wird dazu verpflichtet keiner
wird dazu angehalten aber jeder kann
diese chance nutzen und es entsprechend
wahrnehmen
wir glauben dass das ein gutes angebot
ist die kosten schätzen wir derzeit über
200 millionen auf das jahr gerechnet
entsprechend der bedarf wird es dann
verlängert dazu entwickeln wir sowohl
neue testverfahren als auch neue
teststudien wir werden den nächsten
tagen ein projekt starten mit allen
sechs uni klinik ars die insbesonders
thema in schulen und kitas noch mal
beleuchtet im unterschied zu der ersten
guten studien baden württemberg wird das
jetzt begleitend zu nahezu 50 standorten
kitas und schulen gemacht um einmal zu
sehen wie sich das jetzt auch die
entsprechend öffnungen auf ein mögliches
infektionsgeschehen entwickeln und wie
das stattfindet sie sehen auch in
einzelnen fällen
die mal stattfindet auch in kitas und
schulen ist immer noch kurvig geben kann
und wir haben den auftrag erteilt eine
umfassende antikörpertest strategie zu
entwickeln weil wir glauben dass das die
ergänzende möglichkeit ist zudem testen
des testens das schnelle und akute und
der antikörper test hilft uns
insbesondere für die zweite jahreshälfte
stärker anzugehen dann werden alle
wissenschaftlichen kapazitäten die wir
haben auch noch mal aus definiert und
vorangebracht so dass wir test strategie
ausweiten antikörpertest strategie
weiter entwickeln um insgesamt ein
relativ umfassendes bild zusammen wie
der aktuelle stand von infektionen ist
und wie man darauf reagieren kann
geschwindigkeit ist dabei relativ
wichtig corona ist schnell wir dürfen
deswegen nicht zögern deswegen noch
einmal zusammenfassend es gibt
verschiedene bundesländer die gehen
einen anderen weg das respektieren wir
sehr da haben wir überhaupt kein problem
im gegenteil wir glauben aber dass das
für die bevölkerung einfach ein
angebotes dass der freistaat bayern
machen kann
es ist keine frage von prioritäten es
ist einzig eine frage von kapazitäten
und die kapazitäten muss man erhöhen
klar ist kostet geld aber es gibt kaum
eine bessere lohnende investition im
moment als dort zu mir sicherheit zu
führen
man zieht es übrigens jetzt ja auch in
gütersloh nur die umfassenden tests
bringen die chance ein klares bild von
infektion zu haben und geben dann auch
die chance den urlaub zu genießen wenn
die entsprechende testergebnisse
vorlägen
also ist es für alle besser deswegen
noch einmal unser konzept für jedermann
schneller und wichtig kostenlos was die
kasse nicht übernimmt gibt viele fälle
bei symptomen übernimmt die krankenkasse
da der bund schon sehr viel
hervorragende vorarbeit gemacht darf
dank eine bundesgesundheitsminister aber
dazu eben dort wo es notwendig ist das
gilt für das gesamte bayerische personal
aber auch für alle diejenigen die
einfach unsicher sind und es gibt
übrigens auch sehr viele menschen die
glauben symptome zu spüren
deswegen ist uns einfach wichtig dann
angebot zu machen
es gibt auch keine begrenzung also nicht
nur einmal ein jazz zone test ist dann
mehrfach wiederholt eben weil es immer
wieder zu einer neuen infektion führen
kann
insofern glauben wir dass das ein schon
mutiges konzept ist aber das ist derzeit
angemessen und der tatsache dass wir mit
einer zweiten welle zu rechnen haben ist
ganz entscheidend dass wir ein noch
besseres frühwarnsystem haben um die
wasserstände besser ermitteln zu können
und werden heute am kabinett lang geräte
da gab es auch einige wortmeldungen
sagten
vielleicht hilft es auch manche
infektion zu entdecken die sonst
überhaupt nicht entdeckt worden wäre
auch das könnte ein große chance dabei
sein insofern ist das geld investiert
wird nicht dass entscheidenden letzten
satz vielleicht noch von mir ich habe
auf der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz vor
zwei wochen bereits dies angemahnt
dort ging es neben die frage sondern
mehr oder weniger testen und habe
bereits gesagt dass ich vor bayern
vorhaben dass wir vor bayern vorhaben
eine umfassende struktur zu machen
da gab es immer wieder aus guten gründen
auch bedenken eines der hauptargumente
war geld und ich glaube dass das an der
stelle ein wichtiges aber eben nicht ein
abschließendes argument sein darf
wirtschaftsminister hubert aiwanger
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
die korona krise stellt besonders die
gesundheitspolitik und die
wirtschaftspolitik eines landes auf den
prüfstand
wir haben natürlich alle hände voll zu
tun die es infektionsgeschehen in den
griff zu kriegen rückschläge zu
vermeiden
wir sehen aber eben auch aufgrund von
corona massive einwirkungen und
auswirkungen auf die bayerische
wirtschaft wir haben derzeit 26 prozent
der bayerischen arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer in kurzarbeit
rund 1,5 millionen menschen bis zu zehn
bis zu zwei millionen sind ja in den
statistiken vorausgesagt worden
es ist auch zu erwarten dass die
arbeitslosenzahlen zu nehmen wir sind
jetzt derzeit bei rund 300.000
arbeitslosen meter und einem anteil von
3,8 prozent das ist immer noch
bundesweit ein sehr gutes ergebnis aber
wir haben einfach voraus hinweise und
sie können es in den medien verfolgen
sie können es aus den
wirtschaftspolitischen debatten
verfolgen das auch diverse branchen
zunehmend probleme bekommen es sind
einige namen von airbus bis galeria
karstadt kaufhof bis zwei akkorde ja in
den letzten tagen durch die schlagzeilen
begeistert teilweise größere arbeitgeber
die auch einen einblick in die branche
geben wenn ich airbus sage dann nämlich
die luft und raumfahrt die ja massivste
einbrüche im kundenaufkommen zu
verzeichnen hat flughafen münchen nur
noch einen bruchteil wenige prozente der
fluggäste die wir vor corona hatten wir
sehen im einkaufsverhalten der
bevölkerung einen eindruck von 30 bis 40
prozent im einzelhandel in vielen
segmenten einige segmente haben zugelegt
aber sehr viele haben eben gelitten und
diese branchen kommen jetzt zunehmend in
die bredouille kommen auf die politik zu
wollen lösungen wir haben ja viele
sofort hilfe maßnahmen in die wege
geleitet wir haben schnell kredite
ausgegeben es gibt eine vielzahl an
kreditmöglichkeiten aber das sind eben
alles nur überbrückungshilfen irgendwann
muss und soll die konjunktur wieder
anspringen damit eben keine grosse
zunahme im bereich der arbeitslosigkeit
festzustellen ist wir tun hier was wir
tun können
wir kümmern uns um jeden betrieb so weit
ist irgendwo denkbar ist sehen aber
trotzdem dass wir gewisse
verhaltensmuster der bevölkerung nicht
ändern können
wir stellen fest dass einige lockerungen
vielleicht gar nicht so angenommen
werden mann dürfte jetzt wieder zum
essen ins restaurant gehen und trotzdem
sind die restaurants nicht überfüllt wir
haben vor kurzem die lockerung dermaßen
schlecht für das verkaufspersonal
beschlossen also die verkäuferin im
supermarkt hinter der plexiglasscheibe
bräuchte die maske nicht zu tragen
trotzdem bekomme ich botschaften von
verkäuferinnen die sorgen aber unser
schiff besteht darauf dass wir die
trotzdem tragen müssen
also ich bitte da ja im rahmen des
möglichen und verantwortbar diese
lockerungen anzunehmen
und eben der wirtschaft dann die chance
zu geben hier wieder tritt zu fassen
natürlich tun wir noch vieles um auch
die bereiche noch in den blickpunkt zu
nehmen
die noch von der schließung betroffen
sind wir haben bei der letzten
pressekonferenz hat ist thema der
schankwirtschaften genannt wir sehen das
thema der tagung in also noch themen die
wir mit guter vorarbeit lösen müssen um
auch hier die perspektive zu geben in
der hoffnung dass es keine rückschläge
gibt weil man eben immer sieht wenn es
rückschläge gibt schade dass der
wirtschaft genauso als wenn man sagt
wird schon nichts passieren also wir
dürfen hier möglichst wenig zusätzliche
risiken in uns nur leisten und insofern
ist es sehr sinnvoll genau und gut zu
testen um infektionsgeschehen frühzeitig
zu erfassen damit wir nicht wieder
regional oder branchenspezifisch
irgendwo zurückrudern müssen also es ist
ein zartes pflänzchen das jetzt wachsen
muss wir sehen in vielen bereichen schon
eine gewisse bodenbildung mich freut
dass das handwerk wieder fuß fasst das
sogar 17 prozent der handwerksbetriebe
bessere umsätze aktuell haben als vor
corona 43 prozent allerdings schlechtere
und 41 prozent der handwerksbetriebe
melden dass sie in etwa beim vor corona
geschehen wieder angekommen sind also
eine durchaus durchwachsen lage aber es
ist licht am ende des tunnels hier zu
hoffen und wir sehen auch dass wir jetzt
alles tun müssen um die wirtschaft ja
mit aufträgen zu versorgen
deshalb hat der freistaat bayern aber
viele konzepte um noch mehr in die
zukunft zu investieren um noch schneller
auch aufträge für die wirtschaft bis
hinunter zum handwerk zu generieren
nicht zuletzt unser 2 milliarden budget
ja für die kommunen und die
ausgefallenen gewerbesteuer-einnahmen zu
kompensieren damit die kommune eben doch
wieder ins neue gebäude investiert und
nicht hier eine haushaltssperre verhängt
so es hängt alles mit allem zusammen und
wir müssen hier aus bayern heraus alles
tun was wir tun können verkünden können
wir heute nur das thema des
überbrückungsgeld ist des bundes das
jetzt
voraussichtlich im juli ich hoffe
möglichst bald im juli kommt das heißt
betriebe die im april und mai dieses
jahres im vergleich zu april und mai
letzten jahres einen umsatzeinbruch von
60 prozent und mehr verkraften mussten
bekommen jetzt für die monate juni juli
august eine bundesförderung anteilig an
den fixkosten die genauen zahlen kommen
schnell nennen bei 40 prozent
umsatzeinbruch 40 prozent anteil an den
fixkosten bei 50 50 und bei 70 prozent
dann 80 prozent der fixkosten die durch
staatliche fördergelder unterstützt
werden plus zehn prozent der
personalkosten die in diesem zeitraum
juni juli august angefallen sind sollen
als pauschale abgegolten werden
einreichung über die jeweiligen
steuerberater oder wirtschaftsprüfer
antrag bis ende august endabrechnung bis
ende diesen jahres also ein programm das
sehr vielversprechend ist es ja gewissen
anschluss an die soforthilfe gesehen
werden kann bis zu 150000 pro betrieb
bei den kleineren betrieben bis zu fünf
mitarbeiter 9000 bis zu zehn mitarbeiter
15.000 euro in ausnahmefällen ein
bisschen mehr
also man tut auch hier was man tun kann
um die branchen die weiterhin betroffen
sind hier nicht abzuhängen sondern
weiterhin im spiel zu halten natürlich
sind diese staatlichen
unterstützungsleistungen nicht alles was
nötig ist um die zukunft zu gestalten
aber sie helfen über das gröbste hinweg
in der hoffnung dass die wirtschaft dann
doch zeitnah wieder fuß fasst und wir
sind bei vielen themen als freistaat
bayern unterwegs zuletzt auch die
bestätigung dass der bund jetzt die
wasserstoff strategie bayerns übernimmt
und fortsetzt bis zum 9 milliarden euro
hier fließen sollen
am 8 juli wird sich auch die europäische
union eine wasserstoff strategie geben
also hier durchaus das ziel in neue
techniken zu investieren
bayern hat hier die ersten schritte
schon sehr erfolgreich gemacht und wir
hoffen damit auch wieder neue
arbeitsplätze schaffen zu können wenn
wir an anderer stelle holte verlieren
also wir sind über
unterwegs von der hilfe für die
betroffenen bis hin zu neuen
perspektiven für diejenigen die sagen
wir müssen um sorten wir haben neue
ziele und wir hoffen damit dass wir ja
den wirtschaftsstandort bayern in alter
stärke auch nach dieser krise wieder
sehen natürlich ist es eine sehr große
herausforderung die gerade unsere
exportorientierte wirtschaft trifft das
andere bundesländer die nicht die
exporterfolge hatten die wir haben jetzt
auch nicht so viel zu verlieren hatten
wie wir ist logisch also wir tun alles
um hier wieder zur alten stärke zurück
zu kehren und möglichst viele
arbeitsplätze zu retten aber es wird
schwierig werden es spitzt sich einiges
zu und kurzarbeit ist auch nicht auf
dauer eine lösung wir hoffen also dass
die wirtschaft wieder fuß fasst und die
umsätze wieder zunehmen
gesundheitsministerin melanie huml bitte
ja von mir ein herzliches grüß gott ich
möchte noch mal einige eckpunkte das
test konzeptes etwas ergänzender
ministerpräsident hat es ja schon
ausgeführt
aber was mir dabei sehr wichtig ist
selbstverständlich haben wir dahinter
eine strategie selbstverständlich fangen
wir auch nicht bei null an sondern haben
auch die letzten wochen und monate schon
viel getestet und wo es notwendig war
auch rein testungen durchgeführt sei es
in seniorenheimen wir haben die
schlachthöfe durchgetestet und und und
dass es mir an der stelle eben auch
nochmal hier ganz ganz wichtig aber was
ist uns jetzt bei diesen heute
vorgestellten konzept so wichtig klar
prioritär sind weiterhin die menschen
die symptome haben die als
kontaktpersonen gruppe 1 zu definieren
sind oder wenn es um die bekämpfung
eines ausbruchsgeschehen gibt gibt das
ist für uns nach wie vor priorität
deswegen wollen wir aber dem punkt auch
schneller werden was die testung und das
ergebnis betrifft
zweitens wollen wir aber auch den
menschen die keine symptome haben und
die bisher häufig vertröstet werden
mussten
die chance geben das angebot machen sich
testen zu lassen
und ich glaube dass es ebenso wichtig
weil viele menschen verunsichert sind
vielleicht wenn sie ihre großmutter
besuchen wollen im seniorenheim und
überlegen ja kann ich kann ich nicht ich
war vielleicht doch am abend vorher oder
die tage vorher habe ich mich vielleicht
doch nicht so ganz adäquat verhalten
habe vielleicht doch auf die maske oder
dem mund nasen bedeckung daran dort
verzichtet auch da ist dann die
möglichkeit da und wir sind wieder froh
dass jemand nicht ungeschützt sozusagen
ins seniorenheim reingeht sondern sich
vielleicht eben vorher auch testen lässt
wir wissen es sind immer nur
momentaufnahmen ja richtig aber das ist
bei allen tests so das ist auch bei den
reihen testungen sind es momentaufnahmen
aber trotzdem brauchen wir auch diese
momentaufnahmen um abschätzen zu können
wo läuft denn gerade etwas also sprich
wir werden auch durch diese testungen
zufalls befunde haben die dazu führen
dass wir vielleicht das eine oder andere
ausbruchsgeschehen derjenige ist selber
nicht mit symptomen behaftet kann aber
jemand anders anstecken der wiederum
vielleicht dann ins krankenhaus muss
intensiv pflichtig wird und wenn man
dann denjenigen herausfischen
und diese kette uns ersparen können oder
frühzeitig eindämmen können dann ist es
doch auch wieder etwas was wichtig ist
wir wollen zudem aber auch dieses
testangebot in den bereich diejenigen
aus denen wenn ich an die lehrkräfte
denke ich an die erzieherinnen denke und
erzieher wo es darum geht im
kindergarten da kann ich nun mal nicht
immer eineinhalb meter abstand halten
da kann ich keinen mund nasen bedeckung
tragen und da möchten wir dass die
erzieherinnen erzieher die chance haben
hier auch das angebot zu bekommen sich
testen zu lassen
und wir wollen damit jetzt auch noch vor
der sogenannten sommerferien beginnen
im bereich der erzieherinnen und
erzieher weil es eben auch einige
kindergärten und kindertagesstätten gibt
ja gar keine schließt tage haben oder
nur sehr kurze deswegen erscheint es uns
sinnvoll hier jetzt schon zu beginnen
bei den lehrkräften möchten wir es nach
den sommerferien beginnen weil hier eben
wir jetzt momentan nur noch wenige
wochen schule haben und es wichtig ist
nach den ferien auch zu wissen wenn dann
auch der kontakt mit den schülern
wir dürfen nicht vergessen dann soll der
unterricht auch wieder normal ablaufen
also ist es wichtig dann dort gewisse
standortbestimmung zu haben deswegen die
lehrkräfte wollen wir nach den
sommerferien dieses angebot machen sich
testen zu lassen
es ist ein freiwilliges angebot das
möchte ich an der stelle auch noch mal
betonen aber das angebot ist dann eben
so dass entweder die lehrkraft auch über
das ganz normale für jeden bürger zum
arzt gehen kann oder dass es eben die
der träger vor ort im
kindergartenbereich organisiert eine
gewisse termin ausmacht sagt da ist das
angebot es kommt ein arzt dazu und so
kann das dann eben vonstatten gehen das
dann tests abgenommen werden
wichtig ist mir aber auch in dem bereich
wo eben menschen besonders betroffen
sind und bisher schon von corona waren
nämlich unseren seniorenheimen
hier wollen wir eben verstärkt auch das
personal testen das gilt auch für
einrichtungen für menschen mit
behinderung weil wir eben leider
feststellen wenn dort ein
ausbruchsgeschehen ist dass es dann
häufig zu schweren erkrankungen und auch
todesfällen gekommen ist und wenn wir
jetzt einerseits ja ab dieser woche auch
wieder mehr besucher ermöglichen in
seniorenheimen dann ist es wiederum auf
der anderen seite wichtig ein stück weit
sicherheit über testungen bekommen zu
können
also von daher geht auch das hand in
hand miteinander und das sind unsere
strukturen die wir hier eben machen
möchten selbstverständlich wenn
risikogebiete da sind wenn eben
entsprechende anlassbezogenen rein
testungen notwendig sind sehr
mitbekommen haben wir am wochenende auch
durch gegeben dass wir jetzt noch mal
bei den größeren schlachthöfen
nachschauen werden bei der fleisch
verarbeitenden gewerbe noch mal
nachschauen werden und hier noch mal
rein testungen durchführen werden auch
das wird weiter parallel stattfinden
ja das ist ein großes konzept ein
mutiges konzept was sie uns hier
vorgenommen haben
wir haben deswegen auch mit der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung ein vertrag
geschlossen so dass die ärzte die
niedergelassenen vertragsärzte
entsprechend eine ziffer haben es
abrechnen können
und wir
gehen davon aus dass die ärzte das
angebot auch gut annehmen und hier die
testungen mit durchführen sollten wir
feststellen dass der ein oder andere
arzt doch nicht so dabei ist dann werden
wir eine liste aufstellen mit auf dieser
liste wo dann diejenigen wissen wo sie
hingehen können
aber das werden wir jetzt die nächsten
tage auch einfach mal aufsicht uns
anschauen wie das jetzt dann auch los
geht wie es startet wir haben das
gleiche aber auch dass wir natürlich
sehr dankbar sind dass der bund
vereinbart hat dass die laborkosten zum
beispiel bei der testung über die gkv
abgerechnet werden können wenn wir eben
zum beispiel in seniorenheimen testen
dann werden wir das natürlich in
anspruch nehmen aber bisher
wenn dann die träger aber die kosten für
das abstreichen gehabt hätten wäre es
vielleicht doch wieder zu weniger die
testungen gekommen das übernimmt der
freistaat bayern weil wir heute auch im
kabinett gesagt haben dass es nicht am
geld scheitern soll dass der ein oder
andere test durchgeführt wird
wir wollen hiermit unsere bisherigen
maßnahmen unterstützen aber ich sage
auch eines das nicht wenn ich getestet
bin dass ich dann verzichten kann auf
abstand oder mund nasen bedeckung also
diese falsche sicherheit da müssen wir
auch aufpassen dass trotzdem die anderen
maßnahmen weiterhin notwendig sind aber
auf dass eine zu verzichten nur weil
vielleicht alter oder anderes kritisch
sieht halte ich für nicht richtig und
deswegen haben wir uns für dieses
konzept entschlossen in der struktur wie
wie es gerade auch vorgestellt haben
ich danke für die aufmerksamkeit vielen
dank vielen dank bekommen zu und fragen
den auftrag macht patricia schäfer vom
zdf
den knopf nicht vor kann man ja vermuten
das was sie angesprochen haben
und auch der ministerpräsident frage
geht an der ministerpräsident vor allem
wenn die leute sich jetzt regelmäßig
testen lassen können öfter testen lassen
können dass das ein leichtsinn beiträgt
nach dem motto ja dann gehe ich halt am
gärtnerplatz feiern und ich kann mich am
morgen testen lassen wie wollen sie so
etwas vermeiden und wie oft darf sich
jemand testen lassen also man kann sich
ja vorstellen dass leute dann alle zwei
tage zum test drin also erst einmal ist
der leichtsinn ja schon da also das wäre
eine völlige verkennung der tatsache zu
glauben weil man mehr testen dann gibt
es mir leicht sind man muss wenn du die
ganzen bilder in deutschland sehen wir
werden auch sehr genau darauf achten wie
das auch da weitergeht bei dieser
entwicklung entscheiden müsse wir geben
den bürgern stück für stück und zwar
fast alles mittlerweile ein eigener
verantwortung zurück nun hauptteil der
ausgangs beschränkung hat der staat die
verantwortung gehabt
es hat gewirkt jetzt geben wir einen
großen teil dieser verantwortung zurück
viele bürger halten sich großartig dran
hubert hat es auch angesprochen wurde um
es im handel und auch in gastronomie
magath zu viel zu umsatzsteigerung kommt
weil bürger zurückhaltend sind nach
umfragen ihres senders ist die zahlt
jeder den es zu schnell geht sogar
gewachsen im letzten politbarometer ist
nicht so dass die leute samt schneller
schneller sondern eher langsam
vorsicht also deswegen ist das erste
zunächst einmal es ist auch eine
reaktion auf die erleichterungen die da
sind nämlich um ein noch besseres bild
zu bekommen was wirkt bei dieser
erleichterung und welche gefahren
könnten ein stehen ist das eine und zu
zweit
also ich kann mich nur wundern muss das
jetzt ehrlich sagen warum man wochenlang
in deutschland testen testen testen als
zentrales element der gesamten strategie
ausgibt und genau wenn das dann jemand
macht plötzlich dass in der diskussion
steht als wenn es nichts brächte der
letzte der testen grundsätzlichen der
fragt präsidenten und schrammte der hat
hinterfragt ob das was bringt es wurde
daher als spaß zeolith insofern
wahrscheinlich einfach nur ein witz bei
einer wahlkampfveranstaltung
aber die realität ist dass nur mehr
testen bessere ergebnisse bringen so
natürlich ist es so dass es auch der
veränderung geben kann dass es danach
wieder zu steigen kommt aber für den
moment gibt es ein relativ klares bild
der infektion und wir sind relativ
sicher in einigen bundesländern hat man
übrigens teilweise das gemacht in
sachsen hat man zum beispiel schon mal
ist den lehrern angeboten
es war nicht so viele die waren es war
nicht so viele deswegen ist das
freiwillige angebot führt auch nicht zu
einer überkapazität aber es wird an
einigen stellen zu einer schärfung der
tatsache und wir haben jetzt mal keine
limits gesetzt aber natürlich ist
logisch wenn jemand vier mal die woche
kommt ist es eher unwahrscheinlich weil
dann ist die ansteckung nicht möglich da
wird es auch einen sprechen hinweis
geben aber es ist mehrfach möglich weil
es die einzige echte chance ist dann zu
ermitteln ob die ganzen abstandsgebot
auch würden oder nicht nur als pcr test
und nicht als anti kater ist ja der
unterschied der antikörper test das
anders geht übrigens auch so wir haben
heute morgen mal besprochen in einem
fall wird ja ein abstrich gemacht im
anderen fall zum teil blut eben genommen
das ist ja ein stärkerer eingriff wir
überlegen jetzt gerade die wir die
antikörper stress antikörpertest aktive
die aktivitäten verbessern können aber
heute dann bei den auftrag erteilt wir
haben ja mit vielen firmen da die haben
kapazitäten hubert aiwanger hat einiges
auf den weg gebracht wir haben es auch
mit anderen partnern so dass wir da auch
jetzt entsprechend aktiv werden können
allerdings im moment hilft uns da
normale test etwas mehr weil wir nämlich
sehen können wer es neu bekommt und
nicht wer es schon gehabt hat und im
moment bleibt nach wie vor die sorge wer
bekommt es neu und wie entstehen
infektionsketten der sind es ja auch
ganz klar erleichtern muss parallel
dafür gesorgt werden zu testen und aus
dem testergebnis muss rasch gehandelt
werden beispielsweise mit umfassenden
quarantänemaßnahmen bei betrieben die
betroffenen sind der mitarbeiter oder
ähnlichem mehr oder dann schulen die
dann plötzlich oder kindergärten eben
mal aussetzen müssen so das ganze hängt
eng zusammen der kirche erleichtern
testen und handel als nächstes uli
bachmeier augsburger allgemeine
hast du dich
das war eine an sie und eine an den
herrn aiwanger anzieht beziehungsweise
an die frau hummel
wenn ich richtig gerechnet können sie
maximal also wenn 30.000 pro tag also
eine million tests im monat machen die
frau hummel hat eine bestimmte gruppe
schon angesprochen nämlich die die
ältere angehörige haben und es
vielleicht nötiger hätten als andere
gibt es da noch irgendwelche abstufungen
dazwischen in den in den prioritäten
oder sagt man diese zweite gruppe da
gilt gilt jeder gleich das ist die eine
frage und die zweite frage an den herrn
aiwanger sie haben ihre wirtschaft
soforthilfe für unternehmen zusammen mit
der firma varia card abgewickelt haben
sie schon mal nachgeschaut ob da alles
mit rechten dingen zugegangen ist
also ich kann gleich anfangen das
angebot war gratis die da wurde nichts
abgerechnet das war ein solches angebot
in der stunde der not
also ich gehe davon aus dass hier alles
richtig gelaufen ist bei den testungen
es ist so dass wir ich habe ja schon
gesagt was prioritär ist das sind
natürlich immer menschen mit symptomen
das sind immer kontaktpersonen dass das
bestimmte ausbruchsgeschehen da sind da
muss natürlich zuallererst getestet
werden und wir wollen auch da mit den
laboren zusammen eben gewisse verfahren
noch mal ein führen dass dann diese
teströhrchen besonders markiert sind und
gilt dann auch gewusst wird das tor
jetzt schnell dass ergebnisse geliefert
werden muss
momentan haben wir keine einschränkungen
angedacht was die oder priorisierung was
die allgemeinheit betrifft und ich
glaube wir müssen jetzt einfach auch mal
schauen wie es anläuft ich es angenommen
wird wir gehen davon aus dass eben es
viele menschen gibt die verunsichert
sind und die froh sind dass sie diesen
test machen können ich erinnere mich
wirklich dass wir in der anfangsphase
gab es
mussten manchmal menschen keinen test
bekommen die sich symptomatisch gefühlt
haben aber martin exakt ja hattest du
den kontakt zu jemandem war es zu einem
risikogebiet wenn nicht dann geht doch
bitte erst noch mal wieder nach hause
und dann schauen wir doch mal was ich
tue und ich glaube hier ängste von den
menschen zu nehmen ist unwahrscheinlich
wichtig und gleichzeitig haben wir die
chance dass wir einfach mehr auch
darüber erfahren wo vielleicht auch
infektionen momentan in bayern laufen
die wir gar nicht erfassen können weil
jemand momentan keine symptome hat das
ja das tückische bei der korona
erkrankung dass es menschen gibt die
intensiv pflichtig werden versterben und
andere die quasi es gar nicht mal rächt
bemerken aber trotzdem andere menschen
anstecken können
und die wollen wir auch ein stück weit
mit herausfischen
und wir sind werden natürlich auch
schauen wie wo was wird angenommen und
dann da auch mit der kvb sind wir da im
engen austausch wie die ärzte dass jetzt
auch in die umsetzung gehen weil wir
schon gesagt sollte es eben doch ein
bisschen zögerlich seien von den ärzten
her dann würden wir über listen arbeiten
so dass die menschen auch die sicherheit
bekommen wo sie hingehen können
wolfgang ranft und münchen
die reihen testungen die in kindergärten
und schulen nach den ferien vorgenommen
werden sollen sollen die dann in
bestimmten abständen wiederholt werden
nach 14 tagen oder nach drei wochen wenn
halt neu infektionen aufgetreten werden
können und die letzten
infektionsgeschehen größere ausbrüche
waren jeweils in firmen und ist das
angebot jeder kann sich testen lassen
auch ein angebot an firmen an ein
restaurant an einen handwerksbetrieb
er sagt bei mir sind die leute auf engem
raum und ich hätte es jetzt gerne dass
ein vertrag sei es kommt den gesamten
betrieb testet also unter freiwilligen
voraussetzungen und dass wir aus unseren
kollektiv testen lassen
die erste frage zu beantworten ist es so
dass wir uns hier mit dem
kultusministerium und dem
sozialministerium eben in engem
austausch auch befinden und dass zum
beispiel kultusministerium uns
signalisiert hat dass sie die testung
und das halten wir fachlich für auch
richtig für nach den sommerferien für
ideale halten als jetzt noch mal zu
testen weil im moment sind ja noch nicht
mal ab sind also sind eher die
vorsichtsmaßnahmen in den schulen noch
hochgefahren mit kleinere klassen mit
und all diesen dingen die sie erkennen
aber in den kindergärten haben wir ja ab
ersten juli wieder möglichst
regelbetrieb dh deswegen ist es wichtig
dass wir zeitnah das angebot im bereich
der erzieherinnen und erzieher machen
und dann mit einem zweiten durchlauf
nach den sommerferien bei den
erzieherinnen also hier sind für heuer
jetzt noch zwei durchläufe geplant und
bei den lehrkräften ist es jetzt erst
mal nach dem sommerferien geplant weil
dann ja auch dort wieder der
regelbetrieb angehen soll
firmen da ist es so dass ich
ehrlicherweise der auffassung bin wenn
eine firma da dringend das bedürfnis hat
dass sie vielleicht auch aus ihren
eigenen mitteln durchaus das eine oder
andere vielleicht anpassungen
durchführen kann
wir sind aber sicherlich auch hier gerne
behilflich und ich weiß das ja etliche
größere firmen haben ja auch
betriebsärzte bei sich im
im unternehmen also von daher sind wir
das sicherlich gerne behilflich
aber es könnte natürlich auch
theoretisch ein oder andere auch das
testangebot nutzen oder die firma auch
sagen auch ich bin bereit hier das geld
in die hand zu nehmen
der vorteil ist bei der test in einem
betrieb ist billiger denn man muss sehen
die kosten für so einen test haben unter
anderem wasser zu tun da werden an- und
abfahrten und alle sind berechnet
das ergeben sich manche kosten wenn der
betrieb getestet wird geht es am stück
und kann damit auch ein sehr schnelles
ergebnis bringen
das ist eine der positiven möglichkeiten
wir hatten es ja auch bei der
gastronomie mal als diskussion kann man
das nicht machen um zu helfen
da gibt es jetzt alle möglichkeiten wenn
einmal den unterschied klar stellen in
den meisten bundesländern ebenfalls in
sehr vielen wird dann getestet wenn ein
infektionsgeschehen am steiger ausbricht
das kann man so machen es völlig in
ordnung wir gehen die stufe voraus und
versuchen viel breiter anzugehen und
damit auch infektionsgeschehen zu
erfassen vielleicht den frühzeitigen
ausbruch zu es kann in der firma sein
das kann aber auch in anderen bereichen
sein kann auch bei sportvereinen sein
oder ähnliches mehr
und deswegen glauben wir dass das die
einzige realistische und ernsthafte
möglichkeit ist gelockert muss testen
er lockert mussten und wer mehr lockert
muss mehr testen
so einfach ist das wir haben jetzt noch
fünf fragen und wird die runde dann
langsam schließen auch als nächstes
christian deutschland davon münchner
merkur knopf gedrückt hatte
zwei kurze fragen frau ministerin gilt
die 48 stunden zusicherung noch das
innerhalb von 48 stunden symptomlos
einem test bekommt und der
ministerpräsident rechnen sie damit dass
negative
testergebnisse stärker als
voraussetzungen in der zukunft genommen
werden um irgendwo rein zu dürfen in
bereichen zu dürfen
also ja das ist das ziel aber ich würde
sie auch bitten uns vielleicht ein paar
tage zeit zu geben bis sich das
natürlich auch ein spielt wenn ich das
so sagen darf
bis eben ärzte und bevölkerung und so
weiter aber das ziel ist das eben hier
diese zeit nahm tests auch stattfinden
können und nicht ein langes auf die
bahnschienen das ist das was wir uns
auch mit dem schneller vorgenommen haben
aber wie schon gesagt es braucht auch
bei einem komplett neuen konzept einfach
ein paar tage bis ich zusammen rüttelt
deswegen beginnen jetzt wird erst mit
dem aufbau dem ganzen das zweite ist ein
negatives testergebnis ist ja gerade für
den thema tourismus jetzt ein ganz
wichtiger punkt wie sie wissen haben wir
letzte woche begonnen
auch im bayerischen kabinett den
vorschlag zu machen
mecklenburg vorpommern hatte eine
übrigens noch härtere regelung mit zu
fertigen zurückweisung generell der
gäste noch ohne test wir haben wir
gesagt wir glauben dass ein solches
testergebnis helfen kann
das wird jetzt umgesetzt alle
bundesländer sind überwiegend darauf
eingegangen
da haben wir glaube ich auch eine
positive rolle gespielt für für die
entwicklung und klar ist wenn jemand ein
negatives testergebnis hat ist es ist es
für so ein urlaubsziel sehr sehr gut
natürlich das entbindet aber nicht davon
keinen abstand zu halten oder
entsprechende maske trägt also niemand
kann jetzt kommen mit einem negativen
test und sagen jetzt brauche ich keine
masken pflicht denn auch dackel der
grundsatz er kann sich wieder von jemand
anders anstecken
selbst wenn er es hat also das erhöht
einfach das gesamte sicherheitslevel wir
haben das hubert aiwanger zu recht
gesagt hat bei der masken pflicht an
einigen stellen erleichterungen gemacht
gerade im einzelhandel jetzt auch bei
den wärmeren temperaturen
wir stellen aber nach wie vor fest das
gilt übrigens für alles was man sich von
zuvor schäfer sagte
es gibt eine wachsende zahl der menschen
die jetzt plötzlich wieder unsicherer
geworden sind denen das man zu viel ist
zu laut ist nicht glück am wochenende
weniger mails über die sozialen medien
in denen drin steht jetzt noch den
letzten rest aufmachen sondern eher die
st wenn ich mir manche strandbilder ans
wie manches an theresa anschauen
das ist schon sehr schwierig und und
wenn manche feiern also wir werden es
jetzt weiter genau beobachten
aber uns macht es auch etwas sorge im
moment sind die zahlen weitgehend
stabilen in dieser hinsicht sollten sich
aber da wird der dramatische
veränderungen ergeben müsste man
überlegen wie man reagiert auf jeden
fall werden mit den endlos zu schauen
können und dürfen weil gerade in den
städten ist die gefahr am allergrößten
in den entsprechenden ausbruchs
bereichen die wir haben
ob jetzt in bereichen die stamm berg
oder woanders da kann man relativ lokal
begrenzt agieren da weiß man ungefähr an
welche person es geht da kann man
infektionsketten verfolgen
sie haben erlebt dass in anderen teilen
wo es um große partys gegangen es ist
sehr sehr schwer
das dann zu verfolgen mit entsprechenden
problemen und mit einer sehr starken
möglichkeit der ausbreitung und ich bin
kann kann nur den hinweis geben
ich bin nach wie vor besorgt und es gibt
für mich keinen echten anlass zur
entwarnung
es gibt kein anlass jetzt zu panik und
so und so hektisch ganz im gegenteil das
ist ganz gut mit einer mit der
bevölkerung zusammen entwickelt aber ich
weiß kroner nervt viele und corinna
macht auch viele müde ich verstehe es
total ja und man wird sich wünschen dass
das jetzt mal irgendwann abgeschlossen
ist
da habe ich
ein völliges verständnis aber es liegt
nicht in unserer hand
es bleibt dabei das wiederholen endlos
aber es ist eine der wenigen gültigen
wahrheiten solange es keinen impfstoff
von medikament gibt solange kann corona
tödliche folgen haben
und wenn man jetzt mal heute betrachtet
medizinisch zu dem was wir noch vor
sechs wochen wissen dann ist es halt nur
einfach so dass es erhebliche
nachwirkungen haben kann auch für
diejenigen die korona überstehen mit
einem schweren verlauf können erhebliche
schädigungen entstehen und darauf zu
hoffen dass im herbst dann auch mit der
kombination der möglichen grippe das
keine auswirkung hat ist im besten falle
naiv im besten falle live und naivität
ist ein luxus den man sich als
staatsregierung nicht leisten sollte
christine schöpf mittelbayerische
zeitung von den corona tests bis jetzt
ja schon seit einigen tagen
und das hatte hoffnungen geweckt dass
man das quasi jetzt schon machen kommt
konnte und was aber feststellbar ist das
ein bisschen verwirrung herrscht
offenbar bei gesundheitsämtern und auch
bei hausärzten
das heißt von aktuellen fall gestern im
für twitter geschlossen worden ist und
den eltern dann gesagt worden ist es
wird nur das kind in der kita getestet
nicht aber die geschwisterkinder oder
die eltern und der haushalts wiederum
hat gesagt es ist nicht gratis das
kostet 150 euro
und so gern hat das auch nicht bei sich
in der praxis war wenn es dann positiv
ist dann hat er probleme mit seiner
praxis die offen zu halten deshalb eine
frage ab wann gilt das konzept
ministerin hummel in welchem zeitraum
wird das hochgefahren wie wird es auch
kommuniziert und was machen denn eltern
die zu einem hausarzt gehen und er sagt
bei mir net gesundheitsamt das
gesundheitsamt sagt das auch nicht das
wäre die frage an sie und dann hätte ich
noch eine frage an ministerpräsident
schüler die afg hat jetzt gestern gesagt
sie erhöhen
kapazitäten nur damit sie mehr sein
können
es gibt infektionszahlen und die zweite
welle ist darum ihre maßnahmen zu
begründen
was sagen sie dazu wenn ich beginnen
darf dass es so dass wir mit der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung eben letzte
woche dazu einen vertrag abgeschlossen
haben der ist jetzt anfang der woche
gestern nochmal an die vertragsärzte
auch kommuniziert worden
ja es ist so wie wir können jetzt nicht
jeden arzt dazu zwingen das auch
wirklich so umzusetzen
deswegen hatte ich von auch erwähnt dass
wir jetzt die nächsten tage das auch
sehr genau verfolgen werden wie die
ärzteschaft das umsetzt
wir haben in der kasse nationale
vereinigung auch vereinbart dass wir das
sehr nahe beieinander bleiben weil
sollte es eben sich herausstellen dass
viele ärzte eher skeptisch sind oder
zurückhaltend weil sie noch nicht wissen
wie es dann abläuft dann würden wir eben
eine liste rausgeben
so ist es vereinbart mit der kvb von
ärzten wo man sicher davon ausgehen kann
dass dort die tests durchgeführt werden
aber wir wollen jetzt allen ärzten auch
die chance geben mitzuwirken
die möglichkeiten und das ist das was er
für ärzte bisher so verhöre soso
unsicherheiten bedurft hat war dass sie
bisher keine abrechnung ziffer hatten
wenn jemand asymptomatisch gewesen ist
und das wird ab ersten juli anders sein
dann gibt es eine abrechnungs ziffer für
die ärzte und ich glaube das ist dann
das was mit entscheiden dazu beitragen
wird dass dann hier das auch angenommen
wird
die kvb wird es für uns sozusagen die
verwaltungsaufgaben übernehmen wird das
abrechnen mit den ärzten und wird es
dann den freistaat bayern sozusagen zum
quartal wird es dann abgerechnet
und wir haben ja gesagt dass wir vom
freistaat bayern her dann hier
investieren wenn es möglich ist es über
die kasse abzurechnen
weil es sich um eine symptomatischen
fall handelt dann ist es natürlich der
weg der hier gewählt werden sollte das
baby immer bei so einer maßnahme am
anfang aber zur portal gebisses
einspielt die
die information an alle gegangen ist da
ist die information über die medien
natürlich immer deutlich
geschwindigkeits orientierter das ist
ganz klar aber ist glaube ich hat das
gesundheitsministerium kümmert sich
darum dass die zeitachse passen jetzt zu
afd
das argument wer testet findet was und
es ist also schlimm muss ehrlich sagen
entweder gibt es keine infektion dann
die tests auch kein ergebnis
oder sind ergebnisse da dann kann es
neue infektionen verhindern
das ist ein so ein absurdes argument es
wird ja in einigen ländern der welt auch
bewusst verwende ich kann nur eines
sagen jede andere strategie als die
strategien deutschland hat keine
besseren ergebnisse gebracht
die strategie ist zu ignorieren endet im
desaster endet im absoluten desaster
wenn wir jetzt noch mal die situation in
den vereinigten staaten von amerika an
drin
es ist ergreift ein richtig wenn man die
situation in sachen zieht wie in florida
in in texas in arizona jetzt die
infektions scheint dramatisch sich
entwickeln und die reaktion darauf
müsste sein die governance reagieren
darauf und sagen wir müssen jetzt mehr
testen wir müssen ein dem wenn wir
müssen wieder lockt 1 machen und ich
glaube sogar ich habe sie den medien
irgendwo gesehen dass ich ihm der
anleger sogar entschuldigt hat dafür
dass er das zu wenig ernst genommen hat
das respektiere ich sehr
also ist die strategie nicht zu testen
und nichts zu machen
eine ganz gefährliche eine riskante die
kann menschenleben gefährden die
strategien schweden ist eine andere
in schweden hat man bewusst sich
entschieden das risiko in kauf zu nehmen
in der hoffnung mit einer relativen
durchdringung in der bevölkerung die so
genannte herdenimmunität zu erreichen
auch dieses konzept kann nicht als
erfolgreicher bewertet werden
wir haben fünf mal soviel todeszahlen
umgerechnet auf 100000 einwohner im
vergleich zu deutschland
und trotzdem wird kann das bestätigen
wirtschaftliche probleme weil ihm die
globale entwicklung der wirtschaft so
ein problem ist und zwar für alle und
nicht nur handel und gast sondern
deswegen also ich fand das letzte relikt
ziemlich beschämend und bezeichnend dass
die afg herrn hüppe einlädt in den
bayerischen landtag
und ich bin der landtagspräsidentin sehr
dankbar dass sie da sehr schnell
reagiert hat
wissen sie nicht was der auftrag von ein
hacker sein könnte im bayerischen
landtag
wir haben da kein bedürfnis in da weder
zu empfangen noch zu sehen noch zu hören
und das zeichnet natürlich im bild einer
tief zerrissenen politisch völlig
handlungsunfähigen und in der substanz
auf dem weg zum absoluten rechtsextremen
gehen den politischen gruppierung
das ist aber nicht so dass uns das jetzt
schockt oder neues es ist leider ein
prozess die afg nimmt einen einen
prozess des abstieges und eine inneren
radikalisierung das ist erkennbar
wir sind sehr gespannt was am ende bei
den entscheidungen um herrn kallwitz
stattfinden wird
ob er bleibt und welche folgen hat für
die afd
auf meiner hinsicht war nur klar das war
eben ein stein beispielsweise in der
letzten woche die af den bayern bewiesen
hat wem sie nahe steht und wem sie folgt
und erfahren sie hier das ist ja ok und
das hat schlimmes zeichen
wir testen weiter auch gegen den
widerstand der hälfte wir haben einen
straffen zeitplan dann bitte ich jetzt
künftig noch eine frage zu stellen damit
auch die kollegen alle tragen kommen
können noch die sich gemeldet haben
als nächster michael watzke vom
deutschlandfunk bitte dich mir eine
frage aus und zwar die an herrn söder
ich habe gelesen dass heute hat dieses
test konzept in bayern ablehnen für
nordrhein-westfalen gleichzeitig per
müller in berlin
den bayerischen weg folgen will wie
bewerten sie das dass sie da sozusagen
auf der spd-seite anhänger haben während
in der cdu ihnen daher auch durch
einsparen der wind ins gesicht bläst
jeder handel denn seine verantwortung
und will das beste erreichen und das tut
jeder kollege das habe ich immer so
gesagt und wir entscheiden hat jetzt ich
bin relativ sicher dass ich habe mir das
heute morgen gedacht in einer großen
zeitung die im südwesten von bayern
erscheint ist auf der einen seite es
gibt kritik und daneben einen wie van de
ist steht mir nicht zu aber ein sehr
beachtlicher kommentar und was diese
rückmeldungen bekommen von der
bevölkerung glaubt denn ernsthaft den
wir dass die bevölkerung das ablehnt
klappt man ernsthaft dass die
bevölkerung ist schlecht findet wenn sie
die möglichkeit hat sich kostenlos
testen zu lassen und schneller als die
der vergangenheit erscheint nun ein
irrglaube zu sagen man kann darüber
streiten was das kosten verursacht das
akzeptiere ich man kann sagen das ist
uns zu teuer wir müssen prioritäten
anders setzen
das ist wahr wir haben aber die
kapazitäten also machen geht es
entsprechend und wir haben bei uns im
entschieden einen sehr großen
bürgerservice zu etablieren und wenn es
das eine bundeslandes macht oder das
andere dann respektiere ich dass wir
können ja auch die erfahrungswerte sehen
die vielleicht zustande kommen und dann
das ganze ausweiten
ich kann mir vorstellen dass die
krankenkassen da noch mehr zahlen
könnten weil es hat einmal ganz wichtig
ist und weil es auch für dieses jahr
möglicherweise oder bis anfang nächsten
jahres sagen wir mal bis zum ersten
quartal nun einmal ein dominantes thema
bleiben wird
sie sehen können dass er irgendwo hinten
anstellen wir müssen diese
herausforderung ist stellen und
mal sehen wie sie in einigen wochen ist
was die anderen machen und das ist habe
ich kein problem und das respektiere ich
sehr
jeder darf entscheiden ich habe auch
noch mit kretschmann gesprochen
jeder setzt seine prioritäten wie ebenso
bis zur nachfrage dazu weil sie die
kosten erwähnen 200 millionen pro jahr
wie weit bringt sie das denn mit welchen
kosten protest rechnen sie 60 euro habe
ich mal laborkosten gelesen kommen
vielleicht noch kranken also arztkosten
sowie die rechnen sie da wir gehen davon
aus dass man dem er all die ganzen
sachen machen können wenn es mehr würde
haben wir die kapazität nachzusteuern
wenn es weniger wird kein problem
und wenn es im neuen jahr genauso eine
herausforderung werden wir das vergessen
also nach derzeitigem stand
wir haben ja all das was wir unter den
corona hilfen bei gefasst haben da sind
diese ganzen medizinischen sachen drin
da waren wir übrigens auch noch nächste
woche dann über eine reihe von weiteren
forschungsvorhaben diskutieren mit
finanzieller unterstützung wir haben da
noch luft ausgeht übrigen glaube ich
dass ich die kosten noch reduzieren
werden
ich habe vorhin schon angesprochen die
ministerin hat mal gesagt es gibt fälle
wo mehrfache anfahrt bei einem test
abgerechnet wird
was also bei einem test von mehreren
leuten das wird gerade verbessert dabei
ist wenn ich das kreuz ergänzen dafür
haben wenn die vereinbarung der
kassenärztliche vereinigung zum beispiel
auch gesagt wenn jemanden wenn ein arzt
im seniorenheim testet das er dann einen
stundensatz dafür bekommt und wer nicht
den einzelnen test abrechnen und solche
dinge sind auch mit rennen so dass wir
da eben versuchen auch das im blick zu
haben aber dass die ärzte
selbstverständlich auch die chance haben
wenn sie aufwand haben dafür auch das
bezahlt zu bekommen
je mehr desto günstiger würde auf dauer
andreas popp rtl ja ich versuche
zusammen zu fassen geht nur kurz um die
bilder von den strand werden sie
angesprochen volle strände an der
deutschen küste
die blicken wieder auf die situation
vielleicht wendet wenn sie dem
zusammenhang noch mal ganz kurz was zu
ihren eigenen urlaubsplänen sagen
könnten also ich habe den eindruck dass
man versucht gerade an den stränden an
der ostsee habe ich das gesehen schon
den abstand zu halten
das wird mein stack slogan werten es ist
auch mehr natürlich viele leute fahren
gern hin
aber ich glaube es hat ganz gut
funktioniert ein chaos ist ausgeblieben
deswegen gilt es jetzt auch nicht
nachzulassen ist den ganzen sommer über
zu machen
ich glaube das wichtigste am anfang ist
das einhalten am leichtesten weil jeder
dann in der stimmung ist wenn es
allerdings dann wärmer wird
möglicherweise und fröhlicher wird dann
wird es nicht ganz einfach werden
ich selber wird urlaub in bayern
verbringen und wird auch im august an
das berühmte waadtländer bei einem
offiziellen besuch in schleswig-holstein
dann auch noch mal machen freue ich mich
auch schon sehr darauf das heißt es
waren mal so wenn man jetzt deutschland
sieht und man nimmt alpen und küste
haben alles abgedeckt und ich finde man
kann in dem ja zum beispiel den ganzen
sommer über einmal auf der zugspitze und
einer felge land da hat man so viel
erlebt und erreicht also da kann man
zehn jahre woanders nicht damit abdecken
also ist auch eine gewisse bildungsreise
die machen sowas will ich auf jeden fall
machen
alexander kain passauer neue presse die
krone war apple hat nach zwei wochen
jetzt mit mühe und not die 14 millionen
grenze übersprungen
das ist die größenordnung untersagt da
kann es jetzt vielleicht eventuell
möglicherweise langsamer etwas bringen
bleibt es unter ihren erwartungen ist
das konzept war gescheitert
nein zunächst mal ich finde dass der
zwischenstand eigentlich sehr ordentlich
ist also da gab es auch am anfang
hinter vorgehaltener hand skeptischere
bewertungen
ich glaube dass das ein großer erfolg
ist bislang aber es muss jetzt
weitergehen
man muss zum beispiel auch noch mal
daran arbeiten wie man es für andere
geräte möglich macht also für diejenigen
die im andere geräte strukturen haben
daran arbeitet der bund und der
bundesgesundheitsminister ich finde dass
das ergebnis des jens spahn und helge
braun arbeitet haben sehr valide und
gutes entscheiden ist aber wie bei allen
müssen sie das gilt wie bei den tests
es ist eine umfassende strategie app
testen abstand hygiene mund nasenschutz
alles zusammen sind teile eines
gesamtkonzeptes
und man kann auch keins verzichten alles
hilft zusammen wer glaubt nur die app
hilft nichts zu machen
der täuscht sich aber die app ist eine
hervorragende ergänzung und kann helfen
genauso wie die anderen maßnahmen zur
letzten frage marco hadem dpa
ich habe nur eine kurze organisatorische
frage dürfen sich nur die menschen
testen lassen die in bayern gemeldet
sind oder auch die touristen im
sommerurlaub
und wie ist das bei den menschen im
grenzgebiet
wenn ich beispielsweise in bayern
arbeiten
württemberg wohnen also ehrlicherweise
haben wir jetzt als angebot für die
bayerische bevölkerung gedacht aber ich
kann mir gut vorstellen wenn gewisse
regionen da sind wo man quasi die frau
hier arbeitet hier trotzdem viel zeit
verbringt dass das dann auch eine
möglichkeit gibt vielleicht besuche ich
auch hier normalerweise schon den
arztbesuch hier die apotheken wenn ich
was einkaufen muss aber ich würde es
jetzt nicht gern
so gesehen wissen dass jetzt sämtliche
bundesbürger aus anderen ländern zu uns
reißen und sich testen lassen
zum abschluss eva eismann bayerische
rundfunk
wir haben gerne gäste ihre kluge frage
ehrlich sein
die anderen brauchen natürlich ein gutes
will habe er sehe da nicht es sich
wundern zwei pferden zu europa die erste
ist welche erwartungen hat bayern die
deutschen eu ratspräsidentschaft
ich glaube das wichtigste ist dass wir
in dieser ratspräsidentschaft dass es
uns gelingt dieses diesen europäischen
gedanken zu starken und gesamt europa
durch die krise zu führen
es ist ja nicht nur so dass deutschland
probleme hat die probleme in anderen
ländern sind ungleich größer und wir
haben gerade fair in der kroner zeit ein
auseinanderklaffen erlebt dann wird es
ganz existenziell seien dies zusammen zu
bringen
deswegen sind die angebote die jetzt
über die bundeskanzlei am französischen
präsidenten gemacht worden
ein sehr sehr guter weg dorthin das
sollte nicht blockiert sollten sondern
am ende zum guten ergebnis geführt
werden
ich glaube dass das eine schicksals
präsidentschaft ist für europa eine
schicksals präsidentschaft und das
wahrscheinlich ging es nur so dass eben
deutschland an der stelle die führung
hat oder frankreich wäre es gewesen und
gerade die bundeskanzlerin als die
europäerinnen mit der längsten erfahrung
die widerstreitenden interessen zu
integrieren und ein europa dann auf den
weg zu bringen finanziell aber auch
organisatorisch das diesen großen
pandemischen herausforderung corona aber
ehrlicherweise auch klimawandel ein
starkes signal entgegengesetzt und was
ich mir auch wünschen würde dass wir in
den zeiten der irrungen und wirrungen
auch ein signal für mehr souveränität
was etablieren können also wir erleben
ist er täglich was die vereinigten
staaten betrifft der umgang
untereinander wie erlebnis mit der
herausforderung mit russland und china
ich glaube am ende bleibt sowohl für
deutschland als auch europa nur mehr
eigene souveränität zu entwickeln
weniger kleinteilige aktivität sowie das
große ganze im blick zu haben und es
gelänge bei der ratspräsidentschaft will
ist ein ganz großartiger beitrag für
europa an vielen dank der aufmerksamkeit
pressekonferenz ist geschlossen
da vielleicht noch mal die wesentlichen
punkte zusammenfassen die schon
angesprochen ist zum einen das konzept
ab morgen auf dem ersten suppen ist also
möglich sich freiwillig und kostenlos
hier testen zu lassen
die staatsregierung hat die kosten dafür
so auf ungefähr 200 millionen für dieses
jahr beziffert und der zweite wichtige
punkt der betrifft die masken pflicht
bei kulturveranstaltungen das soll
künftig wie bei gottesdiensten
gehandhabt werden also bis zum platz mit
maske und stand kann man das
kulturereignis ohne maske genießen
herzlichen dank für ihr interesse alle
weiteren informationen von sie aufwerfen
20 de